you used to have to literally get out of
your house to go be a stripper or a
hooker or a woman of the night now you
could just do it in the comfort of your
home with a webcam okay so women are
able to monetize their sexuality like
never before
um
combined with that are the the hookup
culture that's basically pervasive in
society marital sex you know body counts
over there by the way do you know what
the average body count for a man versus
a woman is in America today oh my gosh
what can I guess yeah okay I feel like I
saw this no don't tell me okay average
amount of sexual partners for a man six
and a half to seven six point five to
seven for a woman four to five so in a
lifespan you're talking six to seven uh
what do you think is an appropriate
amount of sexual partners before
marriage
personally yeah
um
none
I really believe it's it's it's the
least practical I want to clarify the
least practical practical the best for
society I truly believe promiscuity is
one of the biggest cancers that's
affecting the Western Society
um I think it's something that's
extremely destructive in the lives of
women
obviously it's extremely destructive in
the lives of men so I think what's ideal
for both individual Partners is for
individuals to build their lives find
someone that they want to be with and do
deep investigation and then be with that
person statistically speaking virgins
and women who especially women who have
the least amount of sexual partners I
don't have that day to apologize guys
um have the most stable and healthy
marriages I don't think promiscuity is
good so you're an advocate of two
virgins
riding it out no sex still married so
here's what I'm getting married like I
said it's not practical so I'm gonna be
honest because I didn't do that either
so it's not practical I think my biggest
advice is and this and it gets really
complicated because it's like this is
like a two-hour conversation that I'm
trying to condense in two minutes the
biggest challenge is that I believe
people at the very minimum
only be with someone that you're in a
committed relationship with that you can
see yourself marrying right
um but that poses a challenge because it
went for girls 35 or so she's had nine
boyfriends and she's had nine bodies so
to me I think the best thing possible
but it's not practical if I'm being
honest I I I I think it's so not proud
of course this is not it's not realistic
today so it's almost like hey
for me like I tell people all the time
my story is very true I probably had the
least amount of sexual partners then
whenever I go in the room I guarantee
you have all like 99 of the time I have
the least amount of sexual partners and
so as an individual who really only time
I really had sexual intercourse was with
my wife
um like consistently I know it's hard as
crap but I can say I did attempt as best
as I could to do so I was not perfect I
made a lot of mistakes I slipped up a
ton but you can at least pursue to not
be as promiscuous and to at least try to
live as a self-controlled life as
possible I think you can try that how
does that look I don't know but I think
we should at least try a form of
self-control don't be hard on yourself
bro I'm happy for you did before your
marriage you're good by the way do you
think there's what's the most
appropriate number body count before
marriage
oh I mean I think the the rise in
promiscuity is on the women more than
the men to be honest because like one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year so it's
definitely the women
um it's a very small percentage of men
that can actually even get sex
um and I would say an appropriate number
I mean ideally like if you're if you're
a young girl and you can wait till
you're married like to have sex I
totally would advise that and I don't
really give advice but yeah so I mean I
love how you collect yourself but I just
I just think like the less the better
like I just think hookup culture isn't
um so I just don't think it's beneficial
Hafiz is basically saying hey I know
it's not practical I know it's not ideal
I know it's not easy to do but you
should wait till marriage to have sex
are you saying something similar or
you're saying I should say the less the
better the less the best the better what
do you consider uh what do you consider
a lot for a girl
I mean I think
um the the data says it switches around
like five to seven where it's like the
numbers drop off
um where like the chance of a happy
marriage statistically goes down but I
mean
honestly I I just think my parents only
slept with each other and I think that
was great I think that was the best way
that yeah like just as a kid I guess X
is no crazy you know my question is you
know once you let the cat out the bag is
it ever going back so whether it's
feminism and women working and being
boss babes and everything that kind of
associated with that are these women
really going to go back into the kitchen
I don't think so now that there's been
sexual Liberation and women can kind of
do whatever and they can take the pill
are they going to start going back to
being virgins I highly doubt it so
there's like this there's this like
idealistic you know lifestyle and like
way of life that was for centuries but
we're no longer there can I give some
pushback to that
Pearl would you say you're a traditional
Modern Woman
no I would say I'm a modern woman
unfortunately you're modern but are you
unfortunately are you the typical Modern
Woman
am I the typical Modern Woman
um
it I would say I [ __ ] I have
am I the typical modern woman I would
say there are some things yes some
things know okay okay and in general are
you the typical Modern Woman is there
more yeses than no
I don't know what your point is okay
because you're good I'm just curious
because from what you've communicated to
us you're like I'm not like these women
I'm trying to improve I'm trying to
change my life so what to me makes sense
is you saw the filth in society and you
wanted to change so I my point about it
is that yes we see Society is getting
crazier but they are people who are like
yo the results from my parents through
what I'm looking at today that mug is
disgusting right is it the majority of
course not but what I do see is that
there are people who are looking at this
toxic promiscuous hookup culture and
they're finding disgusting it and I
think can you do a poll from our
audience if they if you the should you
wait till marriage to have sex I just
frame it however you want to frame it
I didn't say that but um I I think that
like the majority I just think it's
gonna get worse not better and like I
don't say this happily and you know I
have my wife's school I hope it gets
better it'll probably gets better for
individuals but if we look at like every
generation of girls who's doing Wilder
[ __ ] than the one before 100 yeah and so
it's like I ideally sure I would hope it
would get better but I just being the
realest of me is like exactly our girls
are there going to be less girls than
only fans in 10 years probably not yeah
but and that's essentially the premise
of why I wanted to ask that question
because we're no longer in like the
biblical days where it's like you're
going to hell if you have like nobody
believes that yeah and and nobody I
think is waiting till marriage to have
sex I think people hear that they're
like okay Hobbies like I hear like
respect I get it like there's stats out
there that the less the less Partners
you've had the more likely you are to
stay married their stats their stats
that can't associate with that I just
don't see it changing I think if women
wanted it to it could but women won't
and that's the problem of course and the
men that wait they're like oh I can wait
till I'm like 30 or the average age of
first marriage in the UK which is where
I'm at it's 31 I can wait till I'm 31
she said this money that's the average
age of marriage yeah and it's like you
know dude wait until he's 30. yeah and
that's the thing it's not like there's a
shortage of men that are like oh I hope
I don't want to marry a 22 year old so
okay it's that that's the woman's Choice
yeah so to me one of the biggest things
is I'm always looking at what is the
most tangible solutions for the lives of
men yeah one of the biggest things that
I know is that promiscuity wrecks women
we know that but I mean let me finish
let me finish let me finish
prom promiscuity promiscuity Rex when
rexalizing women and so the biggest
things that I've seen that happen and we
gotta fix it we got to do something
that's excited to fix it but promiscuity
also wrecks men and one of the biggest
things I always talk about is that in
the black community one of the biggest
issues with single motherhood is also a
byproduct of promiscuity in the lives of
men as well so to me I un like I'm not
in regards to this topic it is the most
complicated you need two and a half
years to discuss it but my biggest thing
is that if we keep on creating a society
where men and women are just sleeping
around with each other there is no way
we're going to create happy healthier
families it's just going to continue to
degrade our society I think that I think
part of you of what you said about women
is accurate I think that the the larger
a woman's body count the more dude she
has sex with I think that is not uh uh
tenable for a long-lasting relationship
guys are a little bit different bro I
say this all the time before you go and
buy the car you're going to drive the
rest of your life
go test drive some cars and you get out
there and drive on some rocks
wait what would you say would you say
would you say he should educate himself
on the car and understand the nature
you got to sample some cars this is my
opinion on guys guys and girls are
different okay what do you call a girl
that slept with 100 guys how a [ __ ]
hoe what do you call a guy that slept
with a bunch of 100 women it's a total
bip it's a total different double stick
I would argue
when you're 20 years old yeah yes but as
men mature as men grow in life I don't
think they're I don't think a guy like
Patrick is looking at the guy who slept
with a hundred thousand girls like oh
he's the man to me I think I I think in
my and the point that I want to bring up
in regards to that the promiscuity point
is that
when when we're asking about what's best
for society we have to talk about the
consequences there's consequences for
women but as men I cannot tell you how
many guys I know who are my friends who
they're in the hundreds of girls they
have children outside of wedlock there's
scds there's effects of it we gotta stop
acting like sex has no consequences
you're absolutely right there's that
everything comes down to risk and reward
everything comes down to risk and reward
supply and demand there's going to be
risk with having sex with a lot of women
there's going to be reward of having sex
with a lot of women again I don't think
that women should have high body counts
I don't think it's a good look for women
like the fact that there's these women
like Mia Khalifa and Lana Rhodes that
are now doing white school right like
the irony they are not enough that's
full on porno stars DP Advocates are out
here teaching women how to be wives it's
such a foolish ridiculous sign of the
times so you have full-on porn stars
saying all right ladies this is how you
have to be a good Good Wife what are you
talking about woman okay yeah that's
society today
um can I ask you a question yeah go
ahead do you think women are lied to
about men from a young age
yeah
okay tell me as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible